Chameleons are pretty famous for their color changing abilities.
But do you know why they change their color?
Well, they do this to regulate their body temperatures,...
...hide from predators or to signal their intentions to other chameleons.
There are several layers in a chameleon's skin.
The outermost layer is transparent,...
...beneath this layer there are a few more layers...
...that contain a pigment called chromatophores...
...which contain light reflecting cells.
The chromatophores at each level are filled with sacs of different kinds of pigment.
The deepest layer contains melanophores, which contain brown melanin.
Melanin is the same pigment that gives different shades to the human skin.
The layer above this, contains cells called iridophores,...
...which contain a blue pigment that reflects blue and white light.
Above this layer, there are cells called xanthophores and erythrophores...
...which contain yellow and red pigments respectively.